yes my life has primarily been as a  theater director and I mean part of the  joys of doing this for the first time  was being in touch with the Deep  commonality in the core practice in ways  that are probably very apparent to you  in terms of the centrality of the  conversation with the actor the Primacy  of visual composition the core  storytelling impulses the processes are  of course structured in radically  different ways the difference is the  endurance involved in feature filmmaking  when you open a play  that's when my contract ends I say  goodbye and the actors continue to carry  the story every night being the constant  the through line across a changing  landscape of collaborators and creative  processes carrying it with you every  single day that is the responsibility  the thrill and the resilience involved  in that I think was edifying